we know how much you love and respect
Maddie Ziegler SIA you watch to perform
on Dance Moms for years before reaching
out to her and today you girls are
closer than ever but your one-of-a-kind
SIA because many other people your age
think it's okay to throw shaded minors
who are just learning the ropes we know
you wouldn't want anyone talking bad
about Maddie's that she has her fair
share of critics but don't worry we're
team Maddie all the way today's moms
girls are constantly getting shaded by
celebrities and things usually get out
of hand
watch until the end to find out which
teenage slap has a bone to pick with
Jojo SIA here's a hint she probably
wants to cash her outside I'm not
playing a character I'm not allowed to
only be this person you know Kathy
Nesbit Stein anyone who watches Dance
Moms has a love/hate relationship with
Kathy Nesbit Stein the owner of the
candy apples Dance Center on one hand
she's hilarious and dramatic but on the
other hand she's vindictive and mean
Kathy is known for being rude to a
peewee Miller Christi Lukasiak and Jill
vertes but she also has a reputation for
treating Kendall poorly in season two
jill transferred Kendall to the candy
apples studio and things got ugly when
it became apparent that Cathy was no
Abby but instead of apologizing to Jill
for not properly teaching her daughter
her choreography Cathy blamed it all on
Kendall Cathy threw some shade
Kendall's way when she told the camera
that despite being the one who taught it
to her she took things a step further by
saying that Kendall wasn't one of her
apples but instead an outsider looking
in Abby Lee Miller it's no secret that
Abby Lee Miller has a PhD in throwing
shade she's ruthless and quick to throw
insults back and forth she is shaded
each and every one of her students at
some point or another but she's
particularly fond of insulting former
dancers like Maddie and Mackenzie
Ziegler and - Chloe luca's yeah
Christi always felt like Abby was out to
get her daughter and she was right
besides calling Chloe washed up and a
sneak and a liar Abby also made fun of
Chloe's medical condition but it wasn't
until season 8 episode 16 of Dan
mom's that a be confirmed Christie's
suspicions a be confessed Jeanette cotta
he probably remembered Jeanette Cota
from seasons 4 & 5 of Dance Moms she's
the mother of Ava kata and she's known
for being a shade thrower in season 4
episode 10
Danette visited the girls from the ALDC
in their changing rooms but despite
starting off as nice did not quickly
showed her true colors she told The
Dance Moms cast that she didn't think
that her daughter Ava had Maddie beat
Jill immediately fired back but it was
Kira who took things to the next level
Jeanette's comments whipped to the smile
right off Kendall's face she was way out
of line
Nakia wiley nikkei a wily as a dancer
who first appeared on Dance Moms in
season two but it wouldn't be until
season 7 that Nakia blasted the ALDC
with some serious shade
Nakia rejoined the candy apples Dance
Center in season 7 and competed against
the ALDC for a title but came up flat
instead of blaming Cathy for dressing
her up in a strange costume and
assigning her week choreography Nakia
accused the Dance Moms girls of winning
strictly because they were famous she
explained that candy apples should have
won the competition and that the girls
shouldn't celebrate their win because
they didn't deserve it
Tami Croft check and Katy watts Tami
Croft check and Katie Watts joined
forces to create the studio 19 dance and
tumbling complex but despite all of
their accomplishments they are known for
intimidating and insulting the girls at
the ALDC most notably Tami and Katie are
known for creating tension between
Michelle and the other moms in season
eight Katy through some major shaded
Michelle and Sarah when she found out
that they had been benched by a bee once
again Katy laughed in Michelle's face
saying that she was grasping at straws
and obviously desperate Tammy took
things a step further by pointing her
fingers in Michelle's face and calling
her
Tana Mungo and Shravan Moran famous
youtubers Tana mango AKA Tana Paul and
Trevor Moran are known for making fun of
people on their channels amongst many
other things but in February of 2018
they took things a little too far when
they shaded the Ziggler sisters out of
nowhere Tana questioned their fame when
she confessed that she didn't understand
the Ziggler sisters at all Tana even
said that she would change her snapchat
name to I don't get the Ziegler's
Cameron Bridges Cameron posted a
tell-all video about her Dance Moms
experience online and came clean about
what really happened but in the process
she threw a little shade Cameron talks
about how nice the girls were at the
beginning but how she soon realized that
she had been fooled calling them Mean
Girls in the process
Danielle brew goalie's Danielle Rizzoli
is famous for appearing on dr. Phil and
telling the audience to cache her
outside to be fair Joe Josiah is the one
who threw shade first but Danielle
jumped in on the action real quick after
being criticized for dressing too young
one of Joe Joe's fans pointed out that
dodo and Danielle were the same age but
that Danielle dressed and acted like a
delinquent
Jojo reposted her fans post drawing
Danielle's attention she fired back by
saying three very offensive words to
which Jojo replied exactly my point
who's your favorite Dance Moms star
sound off in the comments thanks for
watching subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
see you next time
[Music]